welcome to my video series of
pyrotechnics explained in five minutes
where I explain a concept in biology in
less than five minutes so if you haven't
yet subscribed to my channel please hit
that subscribe button first in this
installment we'll be talking about the
northern what
so northern blot in short it's a
technique which is used to detect our
RNA of interest in a sample so let's say
in this circle cell line we want to
detect that our gene of interest is
expressed or not the way we can do it is
to define or to find the RNA which is
produced from the gene of interest X so
we are going to target RNA X in this
sample so first we need to isolate the
whole RNA the whole RNA after the whole
Ernest extraction we can run the sample
in the jail now after the chill running
so after the jail running the samples
would be separated and there would be
ribosomal RNA mRNA of different lengths
so everything would be in the gel but on
the June we cannot manipulate it any
further so we have to transfer it into a
membrane and just like in Western we use
PVDF membrane here in case of northern
blot we use nylon membrane which is
positively charged and RNA is negatively
charged so the electric electrical
transfer method to transfer RNA is
negatively charged ion is from jail to
the membrane now once it is in the
membrane we can put the membrane in an
UV incubator
now this UV incubator inside the UVA
look you better
the nylon membrane would cross link with
the RNA present on it so now it's
permanently fixed on the nylon membrane
so one alternative to nylon membrane is
dye as a benzyl oxy methyl
but it is case specific only some case
where nitrocellulose on nylon membrane
does not work then this alternative is
there now the most important step is a
probe hybridization step so we have to
give probe so we know we want to detect
change in gene of interest x so the
probe is against that
against the ex mRNA and it is labeled
with a radio level let's say but nobody
used radio level these days so yeah it
will use power generated levels or
oxygen level etc which they can later
detect colorimetric wait but that time
when northern blot was invented they use
a radioactive level now the probe
hybridization works by complementary
base pairing so the probe would
complementary base pair with the
commander of interest and if the probe
is nonspecific then it would be washed
away when we are washing the membrane
with the buffer so only the specific
interaction is retained and all the
nonspecific interactions are washed away
after that we kind of develop the
membrane and get autoradiograph of that
and this is how our radio graph would
look like and that is how the scientist
would understand yeah the mRNA x is
present in this sample and this is the
usage of northern blot but northern blot
is very quantitative and useful if we do
a densitometric analysis after the after
we get the radiograph but the problem
with this technique is it is hazardous
because of radioactive probes and it is
slow takes a lot of time but these days
reals and quantitative PCR is a lot lot
better technique and it's faster it is
more sensitive than northern blot but
still real time in real time PCR you
would have some kind of amplification
error there is a chance of it but in
northern blot you don't have that chance
so the quantification is more reliable
in case of northern blot people say old
is cold but yeah this technique is
almost absolute these days nobody used
northern blot but still it's good to
know about the elegant method that was
developed in our late 90s so if you
liked this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you